[Music]
this week francis haugen a former
facebook employee has been talking to
mps in london
about online harm but is something more
nefarious afoot is this a grave threat
to free speech
i'm joined now by ben smith the new york
times media columnist and glenn
greenwald the journalist who's based in
brazil
ben i'll start with you in your column
or last column you described francis
haugen as a power player
as far as i can see it she's not exactly
a whistleblower in the normal sense of
the word even though everybody's calling
her a whistleblower
did i yikes um
you know i guess i think she is actually
a fairly traditional whistleblower she's
somebody who works inside a big
institution who didn't like what she saw
and went to um to the government in the
media
also taking with her
a huge trove of documents um
you know i do think there is a for a lot
of people in that position there's
basically a choice that i know glenn has
you know it's a difficult choice
actually of do you
you know
do you stay secret in which case the
only people who know you who you are are
your enemies which is to say the people
you used to work for
or do you
become public either because you like
the idea of being a public figure and an
advocate or because it provides a kind
of protection and makes it harder for
your
former employer to go after you but also
makes you a target and potentially a lot
and and turns
you into sort of a line of attack and a
distraction potentially from the
documents than from what you what you
leaked and you know i do think there's
this sort of question of and i think the
journal didn't really write much about
how again her point of view wasn't
particularly reflected in their articles
like they took that you know they looked
at the documents they took their own
line on them um and didn't kind of
filter them through her lens which i
think is basically appropriate but she
has a kind of a eccentric lens it's the
wrong word but like not a conventional
set of views she's against encryption
she's for certain kinds she has a lot of
thoughts about algorithms she doesn't
have a
a a sort of set of views that fits
neatly into the political landscape
you're being very fair there but she was
at some point her her calls her
whistleblowing was taken over by
a communication firm run by bill burton
who's a former
deputy white house press secretary under
obama
um
there's a there is a politicized agenda
behind
um her press campaign and it's become
coordinated with lots of different other
magazines now hasn't it
magazines i don't think there's a large
magazine conspiracy here no i mean what
i'm saying at some point in september
which is to say
so she she went to a firm called
whistleblower aid which is a non-profit
law firm that helped her through and
that she worked with i think through
much of the year so she
by which point she'd given the wall
street journal all these documents in
the journal most i think to me like the
most there's been a lot of interesting
writing about these documents but the
journals is they had a lot of time with
them and it's really the definitive
stuff um
and
and so and then come
i guess mid-september so after all
that's done and and just as she was
about to go on 60 minutes she hired a
fancy pr firm but and and there is now a
kind of swirl of conspiracy around her
fancy pr firm but i don't know if i was
a whistleblower i was about to go in 16
minutes i'd probably hire a fancy pr for
him to help me prepare like i don't
think there was
i don't know and and
yeah i i mean i having dug into it a bit
i i there was less of that than i
expected honestly what i meant by the
other media titles is that she just got
other media titles got involved with it
well she offered i mean there was a huge
i mean she has this huge trove of
documents you've given them exclusively
to the journal everybody else wanted
them
you know she had a point of view on who
she wanted to have them and how you know
and i think there is again like always a
question of do you just dump them all on
the internet for interpretation
misinterpretation you know this they're
full of unredacted names of random
individuals who work for facebook do you
give them to a reporter who will
interpret them i think she's trying to
find some kind of middle ground where
she gives them to a lot of reporters who
will interpret them so which i don't
think it's been like perfectly executed
but i don't think it's that interesting
ben you know a fair bit about
whistleblowing
uh what do you think about this story
and what do you think about
whistleblower aid which is a group that
is funded by your old boss
yeah i think the question of whether
she's a whistleblower is a little bit of
a semantic distraction i largely agree
with ben that she did take documents
without authorization from a powerful
corporation and
brought them to the media for public
reporting because she believed the
public had the right to know in that
sense i
think she falls at least into a very
broadly defined range of what
whistleblowing is generally
whistleblowing by its definition means
you're blowing the whistle on wrongdoing
or corruption
and that's where i think the
question is interesting i'm not i don't
think
that the document she revealed told us
very much about facebook we didn't
already know
there has been reporting on almost all
of this as opposed to say what edward
snowden revealed which
basically nobody knew or chelsea manning
which basically nobody knew most of what
she these documents are revealing or
things that have been alleged about
facebook or even demonstrated about
facebook
for a long time i think what's more
interesting is how she's being
weaponized and
the
central storyline of
her emergence is really not these
documents but her
wide range of opinions some of which ben
alluded to
she's against encryption she doesn't
think facebook should be
uh
smashed or broken up under antitrust
laws she obviously does believe though
there's insufficient amounts of
censorship or content moderation
whatever you want to call it
and that's where i do think that the
groups that are working with her
come into play because
the context for all of this is that the
democratic party since 2016 blame
facebook for their loss to trump
they have blamed facebook over the last
four years for the emergence of
right-wing
uh ideologues and polemicists and for
giving them a platform they obviously
are agitating for greater censorship of
them and so the fact that she's working
for example with this whistleblower aid
group which is funded in part by pierrot
mittiard the former uh my former
publisher at the intercept um who has a
lot of strong opinions about the need
for greater content moderation and
whistleblower 8 itself is founded by
mark zaid who
kind of became the social media
celebrity
by spending four years just publishing
standard anti-trump resistance direct on
twitter
and it's a very odd kind of
label for this organization claiming
they're in defensive whistleblowers
since mark zaid was one of the primary
and still is critics of both julian
assange and edward snowden believes that
both
should be imprisoned for decades a
really weird whistleblower advocate he
seems much more interested in
whistleblowers when they
advanced a certain agenda so that i
think is what matters is how she's being
exploited she's in london to talk about
a bill that may impose criminal
penalties on social media companies that
allow content that governments or
whoever
believe is harmful or foul in the words
of boris johnson there's a clear agenda
going on
that
in part she agrees with but i think in
part she's being exploited to advance
and the the agenda seems to be pushed
quite happily by let's call it legacy
media you know traditional media
is this just a sort of resentment
among
our industry for what facebook is doing
to us
i don't think it's just that i mean
obviously
facebook is a huge competitor
to the largest corporate media outlets
but also to small newspapers small
newspapers are dying across the united
states in large part because google and
facebook have taken all the ad revenue
that once sustained them so this
competition
is very real i think though there's on
the level of national media an
ideological war going on for who i mean
the facebook is one of the most potent
instruments ever devised for controlling
the dissemination of information around
the world there are two billion users or
however many
are
is the accurate account it has
incredible influence as do as does
google's youtube
on the politics of numerous
strategically critical countries and i
think what's going on is a war over who
gets to wield that power do we leave
that power in the hands of mark
zuckerberg
and google executives to decide what can
and can't be heard on the internet
or do we allow tech reporters at the new
york times and disinformation
units of nbc news to pressure these
companies to censor more in accordance
with their ideology or do we allow the
democratic party as they're doing to
explicitly threaten these companies and
if they don't start censoring more
they'll be subjected to regulatory and
legal reprisals or even in the uk and
canada where they're being threatened
with criminal prosecution if they don't
censor more i think that's really what
the key context here is is that facebook
is and google are uniquely powerful
weapons of information and there's a war
going on currently over who gets to
decide how those weapons are utilized um
so i hesitate to pick a fight an
argument with glenn greenwald because
not only will i lose but he will never
let it go and will be
will be owning me on twitter for for
years to come
um
but i i think that he oversimplified
this in various ways one is that the you
know as i totally agree that francis
howard's
revelations were not
on an order of magnitude of edward
snowden's weren't
but but i also think that you know what
exactly is new is complicated a lot of
the things that snowden revealed were in
some ways known there had been earlier
whistleblowers you had been writing
about them glenn that's why he found you
not everything not a lot of the worst
details but sometimes
a new
massively causes something to break into
the public consciousness and the
legislative
consciousness even though bits and
pieces of it were previously known and
so i and i think that that's true here
the that
i told she couldn't there wasn't some
massive new revelation but for instance
the kind of detailed internal
conversations about what happened after
they switched to this metric called
meaningful social engagement what the
internal arguments were what the
trade-offs were how they
you you know what the internal
recommendations they took and ignored
were was really new and was interesting
i thought and it wasn't it was sort of
the the technical mechanics of stuff
that you could see from the outside um
so i think that was new and then i think
i guess i don't really think the word
censorship is the right word here there
is real censorship trump was deleted
trump's account was suspended that
censorship clearly but i don't think a
choice
facebook banned the linking to the new
york post article or twitter ban yeah on
facebook yeah that's that's sure
censorship seems like a good word for
that but whether you show my whether
whether you actively display
content is it what i mean
i'm gonna post that the vaccine
puts magnets in your body and and causes
you to get magnetized i kind of think i
should probably be allowed to post that
on my personal facebook page
the choice of whether to distribute that
to your grandmother or not
is a complicated choice and whether you
do it or not it's not
a stranger who doesn't follow me just
because lots of people argue with me i
post something and saying lots of people
argue with me facebook then chooses to
display it to my grandmother to your
grandmother who has no connection to me
i don't think it's calling for
censorship to say hey don't display that
to glenn's grandmother it is calling for
not amplifying for muting or downplaying
certain kinds of information it's an
argument about distribution but i don't
think censorship's the right word for
that like facebook's making an active
decision to display insane and sane and
wonderful things and bad things and the
dress which i published at buzzfeed was
wonderful to lots and lots of people who
didn't actually sign up and ask for that
thing right so
i don't think it's censorship to not ben
it's quite odd is it not that it is
always facebook at these sort of
governmental inquiries it's always
facebook that is in the the sites of
governments
i think if the spectator was as powerful
as facebook lots of people would care
about the stuff
yeah except except i mean probably the
most powerful company
um
is is not even facebook but google and
there seems to be a lot less attention
on on them
um i mean they're more powerful i think
in enormous ways including what you end
up finding on the internet obviously
they control youtube which is a gigantic
platform there was just a really
interesting article today in the new
york times on scientists who are mapping
out the brains
of fruit flies in order to do that they
need to rely on google's artificial
intelligence scientists which google
basically has a virtual monopoly on um
and very few people know even what it is
that they're doing i think google's
probably the most powerful company ever
in existence so i think it is
interesting that there is so much
attention on facebook and i think part
of that is sometimes just kind of
a little bit of a coincidence that there
was this person from facebook maybe if
there was from google we'd be talking
about google instead
but i think facebook has become more of
a lightning rod because
and this often gets lost is
most of these tech executives these
founders of companies like jack dorsey
and and certainly mark zuckerberg when
they began their vision was never that
they would be involved in censorship
fights or content moderation or whatever
you want to call it obviously why would
they want that they wanted as many
people on their platforms as possible
they didn't want to be in the process in
the habit of kicking people off
but beyond that they had they came from
this kind of libertarian ideology i mean
if you read kind of the triumphalist
euphoric
essays about the power of the internet
in the mid 90s and into the arts it was
very much this idea that it would
empower human beings to communicate
without the interference of centralized
corporate and state control that was the
ideology that they grew out of and a lot
of the censorship that these companies
now practice
are the byproduct of the fact that
they're receiving tons of external
pressure from corporate media outlets
from democratic party from various
there's such naivete to say that what's
happening on facebook is communication
without corporate or state control when
in fact you have a highly centralized
corporation making decisions about what
gets distributed no it's not
a realization i know there's always that
control i know but no but but when they
began there was none
and when twitter became they were there
was none
and when google actually started their
idea was we'll never tinker with the
algorithms and the reason this happened
if you go and talk to people like jack
dorsey or mark zuckerberg is they'll say
we this obligation was foisted upon us
by a society that told us that if we
don't undertake this responsibility to
police the internet responsibly
that the results of free speech and the
blood that it sheds will be on our hands
and they're clearly
there clearly is
a very aggressive and coordinated
campaign to pressure these companies to
censor more democratic members of
congress have summoned these tech
executives
four times in the last 12 months to be
interrogated before them and each time
they say to them explicitly
our problem with you is not that you're
censoring
too much it's that you're not censoring
enough and if you don't start getting
more hate speech and disinformation as
we understand it off of your platforms
you're going to pay a price legally and
in terms of regulation that is the
conflict explicitly being undertaken
i mean i think i agree with you on the
motivations around kind of the
post-trump freak out and seeing facebook
as the sole reason or russia and they're
kind of but i also think that there was
a shift from like no one is there is no
call to censor my texts with you even if
we are
fermenting if even if i'm texting you
disinformation because there's an
understanding that like that that's a
passive medium that at t is providing us
to text
facebook when it was displaying things
in a reverse chronological feed from
your friends was a different company
than when facebook was choosing which
content to distribute and
spread widely and which not once they
are making those choices it seems
totally reasonable for lots of different
people to have opinions on the choices
that they're making it's not passive
it's not neutral there's no there's no
neutral space where they're just saying
well we're just throwing it all out
there and whatever wins wins it's all
active choices and so i don't see why
lots of people shouldn't have opinions
on those choices that they're making
about what to publish and what to
distribute right so let me just i think
this is the key i totally agree that
this distinction that ben is drawing
between
passive permission to users to publish
whatever they want and active decisions
to algorithmically promote or suppress
things is a critical distinction once
they get into the role of
algorithmically promoting or suppressing
they're really kind of like
a publisher like the new york times
actually and ben is right once you start
making those choices you can be
criticized like people criticize new
york times all the time for stuff that
they choose to publish or withhold the
difference though
is if
the democratic party started dragging
you know
executive editors and senior editors of
the new york times before the congress
to say you better stop publishing op-eds
like this or we're going to be punishing
you legally people would understand
that's really menacing
so if what facebook you are doing is
similar that we should see the same
danger there
i think it is dangerous and menacing i
think also remember the phrase was a
vast cultural wasteland television
executives were always getting dragged
in front of congress to get yelled at
about the garbage they were spreading
that's long i mean you know that's
that's that's most of the second half of
the 20th century i mean i don't think
yeah yeah
and people reacted to that very poorly
like part of the reason
there is television news love it or hate
it that is tries to be factual and fair
is because they were under all this
pressure
from congress and from citizens not just
to provide entertaining garbage i mean
like that was that's that's the history
of the television industry this isn't
some like radical new twist no exactly i
agree that if the democratic party was
saying my opinion about facebook is it
permits too much right-wing opinion to
be heard that it makes ben shapiro be
able to reach 5 million people and that
seems bad i have no problem with that
when you start saying if you continue to
allow ben shapiro to be heard on your
platform we're going to pass laws or
enact regulations designed to punish you
in in retaliation for allowing ideas
that we dislike to be heard then it
becomes an entirely different
type of of reaction you move from
critique to state control and there's
actually you know supreme court cases
that say obviously the first amendment
bars the congress from directly
censoring right congress couldn't pass a
law
that said facebook is hereby prohibited
from allowing any pro-republican party
content on their platform but there's
case law where
state officials in the past have kind of
coerced or implicitly threatened
bookstores or other book distributors to
say
if you continue to allow these books
that we think are too risque to be
available in the bookstore you're going
to have a lot of problems with their
zoning commission and state you know
supreme court has said once you start
doing that kind of coercion
you really get into a realm where it
becomes more like the kind of direct
censorship the first amendment prohibits
then just to say i i can listen to you
both are you about free speech or long
but i know ben's got to go ben i'll let
you have the last word then i think we
better wrap it up
oh wow the last word i mean i i guess i
i agree with a lot of what ben said what
glenn is saying i think there's a ton of
danger here when the government is
involved in in speech i just think that
and i guess in some ways it's easier to
for me to talk about the vaccines stuff
than about politics because i think
there's less space for legitimate
disagreement and i think the question
which i think is actually hard to answer
is you know how many
cops would have marched on new york city
hall yesterday denouncing vaccines
without facebook right i'm not really
sure i actually don't i think that
that's a really interesting question but
i think probably some that there
probably is some effect on something
that is just obviously making society
like just an obvious social ill that i
think it's reasonable for legislators to
think about you know how can you improve
public health by getting people
vaccinated and not have people spread
lies about vaccines that doesn't seem
crazy to me i totally agree it's a foot
on a slippery slope and all sorts of
other crazy stuff but i don't know i
don't think it's that simple
glenn and ben thank you very much indeed
[Music]
you